a baby mysteriously kidnapped in 1964
may finally have been found more than
half a century later Chester and Dora
Franz acts son was taken from a Chicago
hospital when he was just days old
shortly after investigators thought they
had found him but decades later they
realized they had the wrong person
Adriana Diaz reveals how what's believed
to be the right person was recently
discovered 55 years after Paul Franz
acts disappearance made headlines
klas investigative reporter George Knapp
says he's been found nat broke the story
on mystery wire.com Franz acts now
living in Michigan and has kids of his
own his children became convinced that
their dad was the real deal
was the real Paul they took some tests
and tracked it down their father whose
DNA matched the baby's wants to remain
anonymous imagine what a shock it would
be you're 55 years old you think you
know who you are
you think you know who your family is
and you suddenly get a bolt out of the
blue that tells you you're not that guy
after all you're this guy you were a
kidnapped baby the mystery surrounding
Franz act began in 1964 when a woman
posing as a maternity ward nurse told
his mother Dora that she needed to take
the baby to see the doctor the woman
never came back
sparking a massive search by the FBI one
year later law enforcement officials
thought they found him when they
discovered a boy abandoned in New Jersey
with ears shaped like Franz axe Franz
axe adopted him raised him in Chicago my
mom and dad pretty much said you're our
son we love you and that's really all
you need to know in 2013 CBS this
morning spoke with the man who grew up
believing he was Paul Franz ak but it
wasn't until he took a DNA test as an
adult that he found out he was not the
kidnapped baby I thought the color dream
from my face and I started thinking
about all these things that everyone
takes for granted like your birthday how
old you are who your mom and dad is as
for this new development the FBI tells
CBS this morning our investigation into
this matter remains ongoing as we
continue to pursue all leads there is no
further information at this
Time nap says so far the man believed to
be the true Paul Franz AK has not
reunited with his mother he's torn as I
said he is a private person
he doesn't like attention he's been
through a terrible ordeal health-wise
and I think he really is concerned about
the spotlight for CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz Chicago
you